[Musique]
au Québec ça arrête pas de changer de
nouveautés c'est incroyable pas de doute
les adeptes de spiritueux au Québec sont
nombreux et l'offre est au rendez-vous
on est passé de 2 à 70 micro d'ici rien
en disant il y en a d'autres qui
arrivent sur le marché presque à chaque
mois
qui est très très compétitif c'est
définitivement un mouvement en
effervescence l'apparition du style
partout dans le monde
cela 75% des micros distillateurs du
Québec affirme être au bord de la
faillite
on voit qu'une compétition qui est très
féroce à l'heure actuelle donc
évidemment certains en école au niveau
de la distribution et leur vente je peux
dire que c'est aux alentours de 650
produits du Québec sont commercialisés
de façon régulière pour les spiritueux
importer la SAQ s'assure d'avoir un
rayon une offre diversifiée qui répond à
la demande pour les spiritueux québécois
la SAQ a décidé dans un effort de
promotion des produits locaux d'ouvrir
les vannes tout le monde a sa place en
rayon
tout ça ce sont des produits de micro
distillerie québécoises
seulement mais on sait que dans les
jeunes produits québécois donc comme
vous voyez il y a des produits qui
viennent autant des
identifiants origines préparés en
bouteilles au Québec c'est pour ça qu'on
identifie la section laisser avec espace
Québec on n'a pas les tablettes
élastiques et je dirais que à la soki
autant l'international que les produits
du Québec il y a pas aucun produit
pratiquement qui sont disponibles dans
l'ensemble de nos quatre sensurs donc
nous notre travail notre défi c'est
d'avoir les bons produits au bon endroit
pour le bon client tous les produits
d'ici sont à un clic d'être disponible à
tous les Québécois
est-ce que c'est difficile de se faire
une place sur les tablettes à la SAQ
quand il y a autant de joueurs puis que
vous avez une particularité si
spécifique c'est très très difficile
pourtant la réputée circadie Syrie et
facilement accessible et est une des
premières au Québec à produire du grain
à la bouteille d'où l'identifiant
origine Québec est-ce qu'il y a de la
place pour tous ces joueurs là moi mon
opinion là-dessus c'est que non il y a
pas assez de place pas avec la situation
actuelle qu'on vit avec la SAQ et ça
c'est vraiment pour toutes les 10 séries
au Québec c'est pas juste nos autres
utilisateurs de façon très collaborative
afin d'établir des critères de gestion
de l'offre qui vont nous permettre
encore là d'augmenter notre niveau de
pertinence de distribution des produits
plus la clientèle choisira un produit
plus il aura de chance de rester sur les
tablettes de la SAQ tous les décisions
qui vont être prises là par rapport à
cette gestion de l'offre le client va
être au cœur de cette décision là
québécoise des microsystéries
revendiquent aussi plus de redevance sur
les ventes effectuées dans leur propre
installations comme ici à la distillerie
Saint-Laurent à Rimouski
les spiritueux ont dès qu'on parle de
distillation une réglementation qui est
différente que si on trouve pour les
bières et pour les vins depuis 2018 la
SAQ accepte que les micro distillerie
vendent aussi leurs produits sur le lieu
de fabrication mais leur réclame les
mêmes frais d'exploitation que lorsque
les bouteilles sont vendues en SAQ
est-ce qu'au Québec un maraîcher qui
vend des carottes sur place hyge au
métro VIP dans ses poches Sylvain sur
place c'est totalement absurde ça la
beau ici donc vous accueille dans une
série toute neuve ça a l'air très beau
mais dans les faits actuellement on
opère à perte les microsys ont vendu 90
millions de dollars de spiritueux cette
année et les gens sont prêts à payer le
prix pour soutenir une industrie qui
emploie des centaines de personnes dans
toutes les régions du Québec
c'est sûr que c'est un peu cher mais
c'est des bons produits alors ça vaut la
peine je pense que c'est quand même des
prix
modestes considérant que les microsys
sont beaucoup surtaxés par
effectivement pour une bouteille de 40
dollars vendu sur place la micro
distillerie doit retourner 10 dollars en
taxe provinciale et fédéral ainsi qu'en
3 d'assise elle doit ensuite remettre 18
dollars à la SAQ qui versait en
dividende au gouvernement du Québec il
lui reste 12 dollars de revenus et
encore moins de profits
soit vous le vendez combien à la SAQ il
est à 48 et 25 à la SAQ et il reste
combien dans vos poches après avoir payé
la FAQ et toutes les taxes qu'on doit
là-dessus on a 5 dollars qui nous
revient dans les poches en termes de
profit tous les frais de transport
manutention et entreposage encourus par
la SAQ pour ces produits là ont été
évidemment retirés ce qui fait du sens
donc cela fait plus d'argent pour les
bouteilles vendues sur les lieux de
fabrication mais le gouvernement vous a
pas déjà aidé pas déjà baisser un peu la
majoration lorsqu'on va sur place et
lorsqu'on va dans le réseau de les accus
il y a une différence de 2 dollars
environ ça couvre à peine les fêtes les
frais de carte de crédits etc le
ministère de l'Économie et de
l'innovation soutient financièrement le
secteur des boissons alcoolisées en
doublant l'enveloppe budgétaire de 5 à
10 millions pour 2022 2023 d'un côté il
y a une partie du gouvernement qui met
du gaz sur le feu comme on dit et
l'autre côté
des finances vient mettre une couverture
pour être certain que toute l'industrie
soit bien étouffée pourquoi est-ce qu'on
se retrouve dans une situation où on
parle du fait qu'on a vu une explosion
de micro distillerie au Québec mais que
cette industrie est en train de souffrir
et de presque mourir en fait sans ces
subventions là
en fait en plusieurs autres provinces il
y a eu une abolition complète ou
partielle de la majoration lors de la
vente sur place en effet le
Nouveau-Brunswick a aboli complètement
la majoration de 70% de spiritueux
vendus sur les lieux de fabrication
au Québec le gouvernement affirme ne pas
pouvoir faire de même compte tenu
d'accord commerciaux internationaux ce
que rejette le QMD malgré ce que la SAQ
et le gouvernement énonce depuis des
années je pense qu'ils ont pas fait
leurs devoirs correctement parce que
nous notre association on a fait nos
devoirs correctement avec des juristes
surement des tout à fait à 100% en ligne
avec les accords de commerce
après plusieurs demandes les ministères
concernés se sont renvoyés la balle et
ont refusé de nous accorder des
entrevues
ici la majoration était revue à la
baisse qui en bénéficierait
pas commencer à vendre nos produits
moins chers quand SAQ on a des
discussions maintenant après ce que tous
les mois avec le ministère des Finances
avec le ministère économie de
l'innovation avec la SAQ également les
liens sont là je pense que si ça n'a pas
bougé dans le passé c'était vraiment
pour des raisons d'argent et de
d'entendre de commerce international
maintenant qu'on a dénoué ces enjeux-là
je pense que ça va ça devrait en tout
cas faire bouger les choses sinon
qu'est-ce qui va arriver la fermeture de
plusieurs microSD est-ce qu'ils ont
raison d'être aussi inquiets selon vous
c'est la dernière chose qu'on souhaite
d'avoir des séries fermées tous les
stratégies qu'on établis de façon
quotidienne c'est pour assurer la
pérennité de l'industrie